[Musique]
et c'est maintenant paris qui est placé
depuis quelques heures en alerte orange
vous le disais comme lors des grandes
crues le louvre va fermer ses portes
demain pour mettre ses trésors à l'abri
on va l'évoqué dans un instant d'abord
regardé le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux ils ont pu naviguer sur la
seine la seine qui monte d'heure en
heure you and roll à bruno girodon c'est
un fleuve méconnaissable qu'il sillonne
sans relâche avec la plus grande
prudence car la scène aujourd'hui est un
terrain miné
à chaque seconde elle charrie sur notre
route ces dizaines d' obstacles que nous
devons contourner super attention
well as faut vraiment être vigilant sur
surtout les débris surtout les troncs
d'arbres les
vu notre première intervention est une
urgence un bateau dont les amarres
menace de rompre un capitaine qu'il faut
aider et une approche à haut risque
il ya un contre courant qui nous qui
nous fait aller de droite à gauche
donc c'est très compliqué de maîtriser
de bateaux là vous en faites pas
remettre les amarres avec les moyens du
bord
sous le regard des curieux ont fait la
guerre ou pas sur la rive des policiers
vont aider à nouer les cordes
directement aux piles du pont
ça fait neuf ans que je suis ici j'ai vu
deux crus
c'était pas mal mais pas de cette
ampleur là lacer ses chaussures m
et quelle opération réussie sur la scène
circulation interdite aura des ponts les
policiers et les pompiers sont les seuls
à pouvoir naviguer
super merci
ici la brigade doit surveiller ces
sommes une équipe de la sncf qui
condamne les voies d'aération du rer est
un peu plus haut cet homme qu il faut
dissuader de traverser les quinze inondé
embarque pas vraiment le temps de
s'attarder sur ce drôle de paysage sur
berge
car la scène continue de monter jusqu'à
dimanche jour et nuit tous les hommes de
la brigade fluviale resteront mobilisme
[Musique]